[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by my good friend Dr
John deloney who's having a spectacular
week by the way congrats on your book
launch John very exciting building a
non-anxious life is now in the hands of
dare I say dozens
Millions different answers dozens and
dozens of folks well if you're watching
on YouTube you'll notice I'm sporting a
deloney shirt that we just got in this
is not merch you can buy a bunch of
people yeah they they printed up uh my
manager print up a whole bunch of them
John's mom decided to just make some
merch to make him feel better that's
right but it's fun so in honor of Dr
John delon's book launch I'm wearing a
deloney shirt I expect you to wear a
camel shirt during my a camel tattooed
on my chest for sure little aggressive
but I like the spirit behind it we're
going to make it happen man no thanks
I'm excited to have it out in the world
man well hey we are taking your calls
today about money relationships anxiety
how it's all interconnected so give us a
call 8825 5225 is the number to call and
Adrien kicks us off in Miami Florida a
welcome to Miami what's up how's it
going hey hey guys how you guys doing
today
pretty well how how are you doing how
can we
help better than I deserve uh um so I uh
my wife and I are um in baby step number
two right now um we have about
$6,600 uh left in credit card debts but
uh we should be paying that off in the
next couple of months here um and uh
another portion of our debt is a car
lease um that we got into three years
ago and U that car lease will be up in
June of next year um and we just want to
know um should we try to get out of that
lease um as soon as possible or uh wait
the the eight months and um turn in the
car and then save up in these next eight
months to buy a car cash that's a common
conundrum when you figure out dude we
got fleeced on this thing how do we get
out there's a few ways out of this thing
the most common one is to find out the
early buyout amount do you know what
that number is um yeah so I would have
to come up with um about
$4,000 um uh because uh the the value of
the car right now doesn't match what
it's it's worth it's depreciated further
than what you owe on it yes welcome to
why cars are the stupidest things we
buy okay so you're four grand underwater
on this how much money do you guys have
in the
bank um well right now um
to cover our bases I mean we have our
$11,000 uh emergency fund okay and then
everything else are kind of throwing uh
towards our debt and what could you sell
this car
for um right now blue Kelly Blue Book is
uh showing um
32,000 okay that's not bad so if you own
this thing you could go sell it for
32k and based on what you owe on it
would that give you enough to buy a
car um
cheap
use yeah so if we sell for 32 um we
would still need to pay um the lease
company an additional $44,000 which is
um I guess the remainder of those uh uh
payments that we owe them for using the
car okay so how quickly could you save
up four
grand um uh
if we could probably save up four grand
about four months four or five months
okay but that would leave us with
nothing left to purchase a car cash so
we would kind of be you know that would
just get you to a net
zero yes so I'm gonna ask a Adrian I'm
gonna ask George a question on your
behalf is that cool yeah that's one so
George he owes $32,000 on this deal and
there is a walkway Point coming up but
he owes 32,000 on this thing if he owned
the car and was trying to get out of the
debt we would tell them hey go over to a
credit union take out this the $4,000
loan and you just drop your total
debt four essentially and so go go to a
credit union take out a $7,000 loan buy
a $3,000 car get out of this thing and
be done is that does that apply for a
lease whatever would get you out of this
pickle of owing if you owe the four
grand you can get a personal loan for
that much from the credit union it would
get you out of this a lot faster than
four months Adrian I'm wondering if you
don't go get a 7 ,000 loan at a credit
union get rid of this car buy a $3,000
car you and I both know it's going to be
a dramatic shift in how you roll down
the street right you're going to have to
tint those windows people can't see you
um but um you are instantly going from
owing $34,000 to 7,000 bucks you cut
your
debt significantly by doing
that what's your lease
payment uh right now it's uh 520 ouch
for how much
longer um 8 months and the thing is it's
my wife's car and we just have had a
baby so she doesn't feel too comfortable
getting into a $3,000 car don't care at
all don't care at all don't care at all
don't you're talking to the wrong two
guys about that because we both have
kids
and it just doesn't matter like Comfort
at this point is she rather y'all y'all
walk into a house every day that's
electric because y'all can't
breathe right the what do you drive yeah
what do you drive uh yeah I drive a 2013
Kia that's paid off and it has 200,000
200,000 miles on it okay you're already
rolling with that $3,000 car cool could
she drive that and you drive the beater
I mean that's that's pretty beater
George well for three grand you're not
getting much you'll be lucky to get a
2013 Kia with 200,000 Mi on it for three
grand in this economy so I'd start your
research and see your options but I
don't know that I'd stick this out until
June of 2024 keep making these payments
that sounds miserable I want to get out
fast and $33,000 may be that may be me
being
obnoxious but honestly man this like
well she doesn't feel comfortable that's
what got y'all in this
mess yeah and I put the kid my kids in a
in a 1993 F-150 that didn't work too
great and everybody did fine I put my
kids in the back of a Corolla that was
golly I just wanted it to die and it
would never die cuz Corollas never
die but they did fine was it comfortable
no did I have to get all weird angles to
get the car seat out yes did I anybody
any money on that car absolutely
not so Adrian you got to make a choice
of what sacrifices you guys are willing
to make and I'm not saying put your
children in danger but you also have to
not have the spect of either we're going
to kill our children driving a beater
car or we're going to stay in debt
forever there's more options than that
and so I think you need to talk to your
wife and you both have to agree on
here's the game plan here's what we
decided on it's for a temporary time
we're going to be out of this soon we're
going to upgrade the car and probably
within a year
right yeah yeah it's not going to take
long year um uh yeah you know we make a
a pretty decent income what's the inome
um so uh about 140 you make 140 I think
you can scrape together four grand
Adrian in less than 4 months I'm
thinking one month a no do a no spend
month we covered only the basic bills
minimum payments the rest goes towards
getting out of this deep deep car hole
we've got ourselves no eating out no
buying any clothes nothing nothing
nothing no Miami lifestyle that you've
been leading yeah we'll get back to it
soon enough my friend thanks for the
call this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become healthy habits
like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with a daily practice of meditation and
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you 3 months free to get started
that's 3 months free to prioritize your
mental health and be intentional about
finding peace through calming music
prayers meditation and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content toward W your faith tradition if
you don't have a faith tradition this is
a great place to learn more about it
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to the Rams show I'm
George Campbell joined by my friend Dr
John deloney and we are here for you
America taking your calls at
8825 5225 if you've got that burning
question a conundrum a Crossroads you
need some validation confirmation we are
here for you triple 8825 5225 Sierra
joins us up next in Cincinnati Sierra
welcome to the
show hey George and John how are you
guys doing well how are you I'm doing
good I'm doing good um so I have a
little bit of an interesting situation
and I'm sure there are other people out
in the world that are in this in a
similar boat but I am looking for advice
on my situation um so two years ago my
father passed away and um I bought his
house um or I I did a Cash out refinance
and put it in my name in order for it to
be um to prevent it from being
foreclosed on um
I don't live in the house currently I
haven't for years but my sister at the
time when my father passed away lived
with him he was supporting her um and
her kids until the the kids got into um
school age and then they made an
agreement to where once once they go to
school she would start working and help
paying the B like help to pay the bills
okay well neither of us expected him to
pass away so now we're in the situation
where she had no job and you know the
house was being foreclosed on fast
forward to now I now own the house 100%
in my name and she is working now
however her her income is so low to the
point where she couldn't she cannot
afford the mortgage payment by herself
so currently I am paying of the majority
of the mortgage um she is paying me what
she can to get by CU she's also taking
care of kids um but I'm married I just
got married and I bought the house right
before um we got married and so now it's
me and my husband and I'm trying my best
to figure out a plan a plan for the
future to figure out how this can
continue but not be such a a big burden
financial burden on us because we are
trying our best to get our debts paid
we're we're following the budget we're
on baby step to pretty much um and you
guys are renting right now we are
renting right now in a different city
but you have a mortgage on this home
that you own in a different city your
sister's still there with the kids and
you're losing money every month just
trying to cover the mortgage for
her yeah it feels like we're losing
money because every um every extra
dollar that could go to our debt is
going to this mortgage well you're not
in a place to be ched in this way and
let your sister live there for
free yeah she's not she's she we've I
got a renters agreement um written up by
a lawyer um she's signed it she's paying
me x amount of dollars um so what would
Market rent be for this
place um if she moved out you get a rent
her what do they pay for
rent I would suspect and I'm not too
familiar with housing market but I would
suspect I could at least get 1,500 a
month for it and what's the
mortgage the mortgage um I did a Cash
out refinance so I owe 119 on it but it
uh it appraised
for5 but since then I've put about
$20,000 in renovations so what's the
monthly mortgage payment
969 okay and what's she able to pay
every month she pays me $400 a month let
me ask a hard hard seemingly insensitive
question
okay um okay
how long has she been in this financial
predicament um she it's been a couple
well back when my dad and her made an
agreement that she she was working and
then but she was having a hard time
finding child care she's single mom of
two um so he told her that he would help
support her um while until the kids were
in school age right um so then she had
quit her job of five years um and really
was kind of depending on him um until he
passed away right and so you're doing a
noble thing you're trying to keep going
the agreement that he made with
her yeah but what we have here is your
dad trying to help you trying to
help and we have somebody on the other
end of this help not realizing the full
sense of their
predicament yeah and she's had a couple
of years is that easy no I've sat with
with with moms who lost everything like
it's devastating and yeah it's her
responsibility to either come up with
the ability to pay for
$120,000 house which in this market in
this planet is unheard of right now I
won't say this planet in the United
States it is um yeah to figure out a way
to cover that
or to figure out something
else but yeah I and I I know that sounds
heartless and I don't want to I don't
want to beat up on single moms or
anything like that but here's what
you're doing you're slowly
inching Inch by Inch by
Inch to exhaling really deeply every
time that phone rings and it's her on
it and you go or every time she says Hey
the air conditioner is not working you
go
what that is is slowly inching towards
resenting your sister resenting the fact
that your dad made this deal and she
doesn't deserve that your dad's memory
doesn't deserve that and it's going to
come down to not your help but because
you wouldn't draw boundaries and say Hey
you have to be the chief bread winner
for you and your
kids and that's your boundary to
draw absolutely and I agree with you me
and her we've had our differences and
we've had had really hard tough
conversations because I have set
boundaries and I've kind of you know I
used to pay her Wi-Fi and I used to pay
this and that now it's just like I'm
only going to help you with the
Necessities you know and until only
until you can get to a point where you
can cover all of this but I'm fearful
with her job that she's never going to
be able to afford that mortgage that's
but that's a choice that she is making
not you she has CH chosen that job and
yeah if you don't give her a deadline
she'll never get there yeah ever I think
that's the next step is we have an exit
strategy because guess what if you
didn't own this house what would she be
doing she wouldn't be able to afford
rent anywhere or she would have gotten
another job and figured it out exactly
and we need to help her kindly to step
into that where we go all right how do
we get you a different job where you
could support paying rent Market rent in
your area and if you can't afford it we
might need to move we have to start
dealing with these adult decisions but I
think what we can't do is continue to
coddle her and enable her and just
support her at our own Financial
destitute I mean you guys have your own
goals strling you're broke yeah say this
way you're broke you're not in a
position to help and that sounds cruel
and
mean yeah yeah it it's almost kind of
scary because you know mine and my
husband's like our household income is I
mean to the outside world is pretty good
but it almost feels like I we have no
money in our account cuz I've either
spent it all on remodeling the house or
it's going to I think we stop sinking
money into this house I would sell this
house and that might be the way to get
hey months we're selling this house
months it's sold and I'll sell it to you
if you have a job that you can afford
it yeah a part of me wants to do that
but another part of me just thinks that
like you know this house might we came
up from nothing you know my parents were
really poor I know but listen to me
listen to me listen to me listen to me
you're going to you both still have
nothing I need you to hear me say that
y'all have these assets that neither of
y'all can afford the way you're you've
managed it right
now and I didn't come from a lot my dad
was a policeman and then he became a
minister and I saw what the public
thought of public servants and so I
promised I would never do that I was
going to go make a bunch of money you
know what I did cuz I didn't Li I didn't
change the way I lived I didn't change
my money principles I ended up in way
more debt than my dad could have ever
been in I ended up broker than he did
it's not about we Kem from nothing and
pulled ourselves up y'all got to make
some hard decisions about your financial
situation I think you have to draw some
boundaries with her and can strongly
consider selling this house and I know
it's got memories but right now those
memories are dragging both of y'all
[Music]
underwater
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it's scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netw Suite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
open phones at
aa825 5225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life your money your relationships
your mental health all of it right here
in front of you on the Ramy show today's
question of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
now you can find expert local help
schedule appointments and get special
offers exclusively in the neighborly app
so go download the neighborly app now to
start getting home repairs maintenance
or improvements done all right today's
question comes from Jason in South
Carolina and it actually came in last
week um before there was a Kick the Can
on the road um moment in the government
um but it said with the impending
government shutdown how do I as a
government employee combat the stress
and anxiety of possibly not getting paid
but still being required to show up for
work is that how that works yeah well
there's back pay so once they're back
they get the money but while you're
there it's not
happening which which means they're
missing some
paychecks I've got my own thoughts on
that I'm the Sole Provider my third
daughter will be here in November we
have no savings and are in some debt all
right so I'm going to answer this George
globally because it's super frustrating
for
me if I had let's say um we had I want
to put something into context for
everybody okay so when coid happened and
we were told you cannot go into the
office Dave and the operating board
called that emergency meeting if you
remember that and Dave said we have this
much money in the account this is how
much cash this company has on hand and
we are a cash only company this is how
much we got this is how much cash it
takes to operate and so you can see it's
going to get real tight real fast here
is how things will go number one if it
gets super tight I will not take a check
me the CEO and owner of this place
number two the operating board will not
take a check number three we will go
into the next run of Vice Presidents
will not take a check number four we may
have to look into like so he laid out
the map but in so doing he announced to
the whole company a transparently here's
what we got this is I want everybody on
the same page here but I go first I'm
the leader I go first when times are
good I win big when times are bad I go
first number two the next round of
leadership go goes second the next run
of leadership goes third and to leaders
if y'all don't want to be a part of that
bye Felicia there's the door right but
here's how we're going to do this so ju
supposed that with a group of
senators who are sitting I just have
this picture George of them in a kitty
pool that they got at Walmart for $5 and
it's full of like bubbles and they're
throwing like Balloons with no no water
in them just like balloons at each other
it's a great mental picture thank you
for
that if it shuts down they still get
paid who doesn't get paid are these
employees who have kids trying to make
it so they're using these government
workers who keep this thing going for
all of us as fodder for their little
temper tanty games that they're trying
to play for an election coming up in a
year and it's so
disgusting how they use people like
Jason as fter for their little their
little future re-election campaign just
pawns awful game of chess and so Jason
if I worked for a guy if I had gone to
that meeting and Dave had said listen
here I'm getting mine if we shut down if
this shutdown actually happens I'm
getting paid my exec are getting paid
the rest of y'all we're going to cut the
low the the if the first in first out
whoever the last 100 employees are y'all
are fired after that I'm going to start
taking 20% from everybody's paychecks
right which happens across the
country I literally would go to my wife
and say we're out of here I don't trust
that person as a leader as a person of
Integrity as a stable operating leader
for the place that I that pays my
family's rent right and Jason a I want
to challenge you to begin to broaden
your Horizon and look bigger than this
particular job because you work for
people who will use you for their own
political gain and it cost them
literally nothing because they will
still get
paid the Senators doing this crap
playing tag with each other and then
here's what's gonna happen George gonna
play tag they're goingon to play tag
they're gonna play tag and then
something's going to set off and I hate
it but Jason I would explore something
bigger and then that so that's that's
the big 30,000 foot view the reality is
the anxiety and stress is the alarm
system going off we may not have enough
money next month because our bosses are
acting like children and they won't
actually sit down and solve problems
they just want sound bites for their
Twitter account okay I'm going to always
go towards the alarm directly into it
what does this
mean George tell me if I'm crazy this
might mean I got to go to work until I
find some other job that will pay me
when I go every day instead of one
that's going to give me back pay if they
ever reopen and then you're going to
have to deliver pizzas at night to pay
the rent and you're going to have to get
up in the morning and drive Uber on your
way to your job that you're not getting
paid for and then you're going to have
to deliver pizza you're going have to
figure out a way to get money and there
I wish there was another option to that
you can go borrow money and then you're
going to you're going to trap yourself
in a continued cycle of debt and false
security and whatever you're just going
to have to figure out a way to work on
Saturdays and Sundays and it's going to
suck but that's the real that's the
reality you face right yeah and what
this is he's in baby step two he's got a
baby on the way in November a third
daughter and there's this impending
shutdown so we call this storm or stor
mode and it's the only time to pause
baby step two St paying off debt and
just stack cash just keep your minimum
payments everything else stack as much
cash as possible until you're out of the
storm until mom and baby are home until
we know what the heck is happening with
this government and so that might be 45
days that sounds like about right if you
wait just a month and a half get a side
job keep working stack all those uh into
savings then once the dust settles we
can move forward with the debt payoff
that's what I would do that would help
me with my anxiety and stress is some of
the reality pieces of it so I and so
let's let's let's say out loud what our
fearless leaders are asking their
government employees to do because
they've only duct tape this thing
together for 45 days Jason I hate to
tell you this but I think today after
work you should stop by a local pizza
delivery place or get online and get
signed up for what's some food delivery
service Uber Eats door Dash inart Amazon
Flex go through that as quickly as
possible or possibly call Walmart and go
visit a Walmart in your suit and tie and
go in there and say hey can I sling
boxes from 400 p.m. until 11:00 p.m. and
for the next 45 days I want you to stack
cash I want you to look at your wife
who's expecting third baby and say hey
we can't go out to eat because the
people running our country are so um
uninterested in solving some of these
problems they're more interested in
throwing crayons at each other um but we
got my job is as a responsible adult is
to make sure we have food and shelter so
let's go ahead and do that and George
just infuriates me because we watch the
news we watch these sound bites we see
these big things like oh my gosh this
and this and this side said that and
that side that said that and Jason who's
got a third baby on the way is the guy
who's at home and his wife who's other
end of this other end of this pingpong
match between children who can't figure
it out it just it's so infuriating with
me man it just it's disgusting at every
single level on both sides of the aisle
everybody involved in this thing just
solve these problems and let's figure
something out like adults and move on
100% well you through this in your book
building a non-anxious life six daily
choices this is George keeping me from
getting I wish Jason we had your info
we'd send you a book reach out to us
we'll send you a copy of John's new book
but there's there are a lot of things
you can do other than vent on Twitter or
X or whatever it is and John will show
you how to recognize and break free from
a life spinning out of control from
chronic stress burnout anxiety and
there's a thousand reasons to feel all
those things right now but there's six
choices you can make every day to combat
that and John unpacks that in his new
new book building a non- anxious life
you can grab a copy today it's out in
stores online in the world and we love
to see it can't wait to see what kind of
life change happens from this book John
go get your copy ramsy solutions.com
we'll be right back with more of the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now to
get up to 50% off that's blinds.com
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
this is the ramsy show if you're a new
listener and you want to dive deeper
into some of the lingo we use on the
show The Baby Steps All That Jazz you
can go to ramseys solutions.com and
click on the get started button and
we've got a great little tool to help
you figure out the next best step for
your financial Journey based on where
you're at today that's Ramy
solutions.com and click click on get
started Mary joins us up next in
Knoxville Mary welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi so crazy to be talking to you
how are you it's crazy to be talking to
Mary and Knoxville just thinking the
same thing how are you that's crazy made
I'm good I
know what's your question today uh my
question I have a $5,000 bonus for work
coming up in January um I think that we
I should put it towards my retire
retirement um but my husband thinks that
we're already putting too much into
retirement and that we should save it
towards our house fund o I think option
three George just had a baby and they
are strapped for cash well do a GoFundMe
yes okay so this is exciting so you've
got a Bonus coming in January and do you
do you feel like you're overfunding
retirement I don't feel like we can
overfund retirement because we're young
and so we can calm down when we're older
and so I feel like we can just go hard
when we're young you know okay so you
guys have no debt do you have an
emergency fund and you're investing 15%
already um we're investing 22% who but
you still have a
mortgage no no no no to I'm sorry for a
down pay me oh so you don't you're
renting yeah okay you're renting but
you're also investing 22% but you're
also trying to save for a down payment
that sounds like a lot of things at once
to feel any
progress
well it I mean we're have a decent
amount of progress I mean we have like
150,000 save for a down payment wow so
what's stopping you from putting that
money down and buying a
house well we got married two months ago
so there it is it's just like this is
all figuring things out how old are you
to
yeah I'm 24 and 25 wow that's incredible
okay so here's the deal you guys are in
baby step 3B sl4 that's kind of down
payment investing and if you're
following the baby steps you would be
investing 15% and you could be saving
for the down payment now some people
like to hunker down and invest nothing
to save up even more for the down
payment faster you guys already have a
giant stash I would continue investing
15% let's dial that back down which
would give you 7% of your income back to
throw with a down payment
correct so what if we kept doing that
when is your lease up with this uh
rental
situation uh July okay so what if we
started house hunting early this you
know spring summer and we added the
5,000 to you said the bonuses coming in
January so you'll have 5,000 there yeah
add that to the savings and then we put
a giant down payment down on this house
because the goal would be let's pay off
the house before we crank up investing
because to your point you guys have
another 35 working years to continue
investing you're going to be multi
multi-millionaires so the real question
is why is your husband fearful of not
having enough cuz if you've has he
crunched the calculators on this I'm
guessing he has what do you an
investment calculator like take what you
have in retirement now take what you're
investing every month calculate hey by
60 years old we're probably going to
have North of6 seven
million well I think well I think I'm
the one for one thing who's worried
about not having enough but also after
we have kids I plan on stop working
being a stay home mom and so just trying
to set us ourselves up best I think for
that
situation okay well that would mean we
need to get his income up and our
expenses down to where we can make that
work because the retirement that won't
really be a factor you're not going to
be able to dip into that when you're you
know 38 years
old so I would be focused right now on
putting as much of a down payment down
to get your mortgage as low as possible
which would allow you to stay home
because that's a monthly expense until
it's paid off yeah that makes total
sense so uh I I guess I'm on your team
of let's put this toward the down
payment and let's get this uh house soon
or rather than
later okay I mean you guys are ready you
have awesome down payment so proud of
you guys congrats on uh getting married
very exciting times you know what I know
you're off the line now Mary but I'm
going to send you one year Financial
Peace University and a year the premium
version of every dollar to get you guys
started I think that will align you and
get you on the same page which will be
fun can they at least go to dinner I
think dinner would be helpful to talk
about this everything's better over good
food so take that $5,000 and go to a
really nice like bonusy dinner and talk
about the future I like that I'm excited
for you congrats all right let's get to
denell in Sacramento denell welcome to
the
show Hi how are you guys doing great how
are you I'm doing very well thank you um
so my question today um we are on baby
step two working paying off our debt and
um we were able to free up um about
$5,000 to put towards some debt but of
course as it goes um now we have a water
heater out that we're going to have to
pay for OU so I haven't yeah I haven't
use that money towards the debt yet um
it happened within the same day or so
that we were able to get it and um our
house we do have a home warranty I'm not
quite sure what that's going to pay for
yet um and then we also um had a quote
for about $5,000 which is about the
money we had so I don't know if this is
a silly question or not but um should I
put that money towards the debt and wait
and to see how much the water he is
going to cost we do have the, saved in
our emergency fund um and hope that the
home warranty covers it or wait to pay
off that debt until we find out how much
it's going to cost well this time frame
is are we talking a week or two to find
out
uh the plumber that came out said it
could take six to 10 days the home
warranty people tend to be slow so um
even now we have no hot water they don't
care about that oh gosh it's awful yes
so we're um we're just waiting around uh
we are reaching out to the I would be
calling them so often that they are like
okay here's your
answer yeah um and I take cold shower so
I'd be fine John loves it his family
hates him but he loves it yeah of course
this happens when the weather starts
cooling down I would have been fine with
it summer but uh sure well I would I
would hang tight I mean if we're talking
six business days what I don't want you
to do is you throw the five grand at
debt and now we know this storm is upon
us and then we have to go into debt to
cover this hot water heater that would
be a bad plan so if we're talking
waiting a week to see how this shakes
down to see if the warranty is going to
cover it which I hope it does I would
fight them tooth and nail cuz you know
their job is to make sure they don't pay
for it and so I would be at fine and CED
because that is well spent if itans
$5,000 for an hour of your time yeah I
guess I'm just I'm curious because if I
if we didn't happen to have this chunk
of money that we are blessed to have
right at this moment we would have only
had that $ thousand dollar to throw at
this and I don't know what we would have
done otherwise oh that's true and a lot
of people have that hangup with baby
step one with 1,000 bucks they go hey
what if there's an emergency over a
th000 well there's a thing you do where
you pause the baby steps we're going to
stack up cash as fast as possible we're
going to sell stuff we're going to get
the side job whatever we have to do to
come up with that amount of money and
those future paychecks are going to be
enough to cover it and that's what
happens uh often but you also you also
have to understand that the plumber the
plumber is only used to dealing with
people with credit cards and so he's
going to look at you and say this is a
terrible decision to F to fix this to
repair this it doesn't have much time
left let's just replace
it and you have to change your mindset
to we don't have any other money so I
want to fix it well I can try to fix it
but it's going to be great cuz that's
all I have right now is
$1,000 and so often it's like well I got
to replace it cuz the plumber said well
I'm going to find me a plumber that will
come fix this thing whether they duct
tape it together as long as my house is
safe until I can like Georgia said I'm
going to scratch and Claw and sell and
do whatever I have to do deliver pizzas
and I'm going to hate every second of it
but I'm doing it for hot water right and
then at the end of the month I'm going
to figure figure this thing out at the
end of two months or whatever it's going
to take so be sure to shop around
negotiate tell them hey do you have a
cash discount hey I'll leave you a great
review in the neighborhood Facebook
group if you can bring the price down
and if you work that kind of magic and
you're not too desperate which I know
it's hard not to be in times like this
then uh we'll get through this but I'm
glad you if know how to install one
right um I could put some we could put a
message up here and somebody in this
building knows how to do it right 100%
figure it out yeah we're wishing you the
best andell thank you so much for the
call and uh best of luck with that debt
payoff and the water heater that puts
this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books I'm George camel he's Dr John
deloney we'll be back before you know
[Music]
it hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsey Way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for the
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
[Applause]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it's the Ramsey show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campell joined
by Dr John deloney this hour this is
your show America so call in at
aa825
5225 and I'm in an incredibly good mood
today because I'm wearing my deloney
shirt in honor of Dr John delon's book
launch week month if year it feels like
you're one of those girls who's like
it's my birthday month and I'm like
that's not a thing you get one day it's
my book day but this entire last month
has felt like I feel like your book
coming out I've heard more about your
book Drama than mine drama yes I didn't
know about the drama do you like this
color what's the right color what do you
think about the backside that is true
what about this I I don't know about the
the amount of decisions that go into
making a book it's unbelievable so and
the amount of second guessing you put on
decisions that you've already made is is
pretty amazing but now you know what
it's like to walk to the world
good well I feel insecure you feel
insecure I don't know if it's the shirt
I feel exposed and both powerful and
insecure I think I think the exposure
part is um that's a big piece he not
really a short sleeve kind of guy but
but I think you uh both I don't have the
muscle mass both insecure and uh feel
powerful and know how I feel that's the
deloney way well hey we are here for you
America and Eric is here in Witchita on
the line Eric what's going on hey how's
it going guys doing well how are you
good good I have a quick question so uh
my wife and I my beautiful wife and I
have been
uh it's a great cave hey here's what I
guarantee he's about to do he's about to
say he thinks something and she thinks
different am I right and you think she's
wrong absolutely yes yes you're right
and I think she's listening so I'm I'm
so guys say my beautiful wife and women
say my amazing husband when they're
about to say and I think they're an
idiot the other person's an idiot so go
ahead tell us how your beautiful wife
may be an idiot
Eric all right you said it not me but uh
smart man we had um we've been doing the
steps and we are now down to just my
student loans which is about $9,000 left
um and she has an opinion that we should
not pay the student loans and we should
just start saving that do the three to
six months of expenses because there is
um a very high chance that her car is
going to go out within the next year or
so uh and we don't we just have a, of
emergencies so I don't know um what you
guys think about that should we just
tackle the how much money do you have in
the
bank uh probably about we have about
3500 bucks okay so you got a little more
than that baby step one emergency fund
and what's your income
uh 150 a year oh my gosh so these
student loans are paid off within a few
months Max the the student loans we if
we really buckle down we could we could
do it
within three to four months I think
three months so 90 days from now the
student loans are gone you said her car
could die within a
year we're going to have a presidential
election you know what that means it's
all going down Russia could invade and
after that a meteorite could come and
after that yeah can her car not also be
repaired I mean it's it's pretty old
this is
2006 um and she I mean she'll drive it
until it doesn't go anymore that's the
type of woman she is but uh I think we
use if she's that scared she should use
that fire to fuel the debt free journey
to go we got to get out of debt fast we
get the emergency fund fast then we got
to start the car savings fund fast
because I know this thing's going to be
dead in a year
versus Le progging you said hey we're
doing these steps well the steps are in
order for a reason they work and if you
try to do multiple at once it doesn't
work it let's be honest though I get how
how much debt have y'all paid
off uh we we owned a business uh so it
was it's been
about it was about
35,000 uh but I sold my business as well
so that actually helped us a lot okay I
sold I sold my business and then uh uh
paid everything else off how long have
you'all been chipping away at
this uh
about well um really about three years
okay because our business was kind of
going downhill and so I I remember I
remember like year two year three Mark
we've been hammering away and hammered
away and hammered away at this and I
felt like I should get my new car now
now and then my wife and I were just at
Zero right we just we did all that work
to just get to zero and now you're
telling me I got to go two more years
and save up to buy the car that I want
which is a used car by the way so I get
her looking down the barrel of are you
serious right now like we have nine
we're going to go crazy and get this
thing done in 90 days and then we start
the savings thing all over again from my
car is this just our life and so I I
think there's some truth to just sitting
and going yeah that does stink man we
worked really hard for three and a half
years we've grind and we scratched and
clawed and we paid everything off and
now we got to scratch and clog in to
save up to buy you new
car right that is hard and that's
reality Eric what is y'all's take-home
pay is it about nine
grand uh it's nine grand yeah she yeah I
make uh 60,000 and she makes and we're
not investing now for paying off debt
right right okay so making n Grand a
month can you find 4,500 bucks can you
take half of that and throw it at the
debt and be done in two
months if you buckle
down we could I would have to look at it
again but but think about that then in
two months you free up 4,500 bucks you
were throwing at it plus that student
loan payment that means 9 months from
then you'd have 40 Grand saved you'd
have your emergency fund plus enough to
get upgrade for the
car right so I mean we're talking less
than 12 months from now and so if you
start to paint that picture and go hey
honey I hear you I'm not trying to be
combative here I'm just saying look at
these numbers we can do this and do it
quickly if we buckle down do you have
something you could put on the
table I'm not going to go out to eat for
lunch with my workmates for a month I'm
going to make
lunch yeah I mean I could I could do
that I'm just wondering if there's
something you could put on the table
that says hey I'm in I'm all in you're
serious all all in I want these student
loans gone out of my life here at George
and I say it's ludicrous to not pay
student loans and start saving up for a
car for another car that might die in a
year that's Madness you've got debt
staring you right in the face pay it
off get rid of that stuff um but man I I
think a conversation about okay here's
instead of presenting the all right
we're gonna we're just going to go crazy
for 90 more days I love georg's plan
like let's let's sit down and come up
with a 12-month plan
here's how this works if I buckle down
I'm going to make this commitment
because I know you're going to need a
car but I got to get these student loans
out of our house we have to get these
student loans out of here let's make a
plan and then in 12 months we're going
to look up and we're going to have
emergency fund and you're going to have
a new car or maybe not a new car but a
used new car A new to you car right
right it's that simple and it's that
hard
Eric I wish it was a
shortcut yeah math and reality are no
fun sometimes sometimes they're awesome
but we feel like FY duddies over here
like you got to just pay out but that's
how it works and it's worked for so many
people we believe in it that much we're
that confident in this plan you got to
do in order with intensity that's the
only way it works thanks so much for the
call Eric this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel co-host of course of this
show but also of smart money happy hour
with my friend Rachel Cruz and the
George camel YouTube channel which you
can check out on the tubes and of course
I'm joined by Dr John deloney who's got
a fantastic show that he hosts right
next door to this studio called the Dr
John deloney show and you guys are crush
it over there John you just passed
200,000 subscribers on YouTube I can't
catch up man you'll have me caught by
the end the month so it's a losing
battle I see what you're doing there but
the team's done amazing work the George
Campbell show will pass my show in
YouTube subscribers soon you just
launched this like mini documentary
episode on your YouTube channel that is
amazing yeah the the the we
actually they came to us and said hey we
want you to follow somebody for 90 days
and let's let's call your bluff let's
see if these little um steps to build
ches talk about see if this actually
works and so we put out a call and we
ended up with an incredible guy who came
forward and said I'm willing to do film
the whole thing and um and then his wife
ends up coming along halfway through the
the the the shoot but um what the film
team was able to do what this guy was
able to do he's just a brave dude man um
and they got to see the behind the
scenes me answering calls saying I was
wrong me going whoa this is a big deal
and this not a big deal kind of some
inside baseball on how the coaching
process works but um yeah it's pretty
incredible go to go to john.com on no
I'm sorry go to youtube/ Jone and you
can check it out it's an amazing um one
episode series and um it's about 28
minutes and it is well worth your time
the team did an incredible J show yeah
they did a great job man that's the
start John next up Netflix is calling
you all right well John I've got an
article here that it made me happy and a
lot of people have sent this to me and I
shouldn't be as happy as I am but
there's those I Told You So moments that
I rarely get and this is one of you love
those here here it is from Business
Insider here's the headline 95% of the
nft market May now be worthless study
finds no to which I retorted they were
always worthless there was just people
stupid enough to pay for them you mean
um digital clip art is now suddenly not
worth billions John it has a scientific
name non-fungible token it's clip art
really fancy clipart Fair Point that
Bill Gates gave us originally for free
just for free
wow through Microsoft through Microsoft
clippy here's some pictures y'all can
y'all can have and here we are in 2023
still talking about it uh here here's
what it says are nfts dead a recent
study looking at the price of thousands
of collections seems to suggest the
answer is yes and so here's the report
out of 73,000 nft collections the
researchers looked at almost 70,000 of
them and slightly over 95% had a market
cap of zero which is a fancy way of
saying it's
worthless so by their estimate almost 23
million people hold these worthless
assets this daunting reality should
serve as a sobering check on the
euphoria that has often surrounded the
nft space ouch and 79% of all nft
collections currently remain unsold the
surplus of Supply it's digital there's
not really a surplus of supply of a
digital they claim you know it's it's
John this is the one token but here's
what nfts really are it's like a
treasure map that points to the treasure
that you're buying you're buying a URL
link that goes to the photo you don't
even own the photo John the original
artist owns the photo you own the URL
that's a flex on your friends that says
I'm the sole owner of this one photo
that you can screenshot
instantly it's that insane like we
thought time shares were insane this is
like a sense of ownership of a sense of
ownership if you said hey um I
discovered a a a pipe that I can drill
down into the ground and get water so
all of us don't die I would say cool I
would like to I would like to buy into
that or if you said hey um I got another
drill and I drill down into a reservoir
of oil or I created clean energy it's
going to be free for everybody so things
that provide value to society I say I'm
going to buy that if you said hey have I
got a deal for you for $4 million I'm
going to give you a picture of a link to
a digital
picture that you can't really show
anybody cuz it's like not really the
thing but you just have the link to it I
be like not even a piece of art like go
buy a Picasso I'm all about that hang
out art up in your I've got art in my
house I deeply value art support local
artist but I can't have it like in my
house no no no no it's it's not even
that kind it's it's an nft I would just
have to say like I don't know I don't
know any of the words you're saying and
so for that reason I'm out oh boy well
you uh you didn't miss out John fewer
than 1% have a price tag above six grand
now which is a far cry from the regular
million dooll deals of two years ago so
much hype and here's the thing the
people that were excited about it were
the people selling it which I told
people I said hey the people like get
into nfts if you're going to make them
and sell them good for you if you want
to hustle people out of a buck but also
but don't buy it thinking it's an
investment I'm going to resell it for
profit which is the only reason people
were buying them
anytime somebody drums up something and
like goes
a and there's not evidence you're not
like on this show you could say FPU it's
an nft no there's a Tracker there's 10
million people right it's not just a guy
on the street corner going buy my thing
it's millions of people there's a debt
free screams almost every day like no no
I follow the plan and my family's free
anytime a group of people are like you
should do it too just be weary just be
weary because man dude well that's the
nail in the digital coffin John and you
can buy a link if you want to see a
picture of that digital coffin for the
low low price of $6,000 that was or or
the market cap of zero ouch so there you
go there's my segment of I told you so
thanks for that all right Ken joins us
up next in Orlando Ken welcome to the
show hey guys thanks for taking my call
sure um my my wife and I have been
listening for a long time following the
steps and uh we've been lately we've
been discussing baby step number six and
every now and then I'll hear in the
other room of the house we're debt free
so I knew I had to call you guys to
really discuss um my mortgage and paying
that down okay uh because I'm more about
the investment side and she really wants
to get rid of the uh the debt so just to
just a brief background we're both in
our 50s I'm 54 she's 51 and I'm a
physician she's an occupational
therapist and we have four kids in their
18s and early 20s essentially cool I
have I bought a house um after it was in
2021 uh is $1.5 million and I was able
to put just about a million down and I
took out a conventional loan at
525 525,000 at
2.5% 20-year term so there's 17 years
left and about
$120,000 worth of interest on the on the
number four side of things I've been
investing every month into mutual funds
which has grown nicely over the years
and I could afford to take out
approximately
350,000 to pay off a significant amount
of that uh what's left on the
mortgage um it's 17 years four what's
the balance yeah
474 th000 okay and you're saying you
have non-retirement investing happening
in like a brokerage
account yeah okay what's in there
mutually index funds about 450 to
500,000 whoa so you could pay off the
house
today Yeah well yeah I don't want to go
down to zero though but yeah I put a
good that's the question because your
wife wants to go down to zero and free
up that mortgage payment but you're what
you're seeing is but babe we could make
so much more leaving it in these mutual
funds the way the Market's going right
that's the argument yeah over the years
it's traditionally gotten seven to eight
per. yeah that's a that's truly a hard
thing to Grapple with for the folks who
love to see those numbers go up and we
love investing around here but are you
already investing in
retirement yeah I have fully funded 401K
it's it's done very well amazing and
you're in your 50s what's your household
income uh gross uh 450 to 500 so riddle
me this could you not invest could you
not get back up to 500,000 in a
brokerage account within a few years Max
two years without a mortgage payment I
don't know about two years but well
without a well yeah no mortgage payment
could you put 200 out of 500 into that
brokerage
account yes there we go I I yeah I would
double my investment monthly on a
monthly basis pretty quickly yeah you're
going to retire a multi-
multi-millionaire Ken and in the
meantime I want you to have peace and
freedom and owe nobody anything and
allow yourself to enjoy these moments
with these kids before they're all out
of the house go on Amazing vacations
cash it out baby pay that house off and
remember if you hate being debt free no
mortgage payment just go get yourself
into more debt you they'll always give
you a loan against that house Ken so uh
I I hope you become debt free I think
you're going to enjoy it I don't think
you'll look back man thanks so much for
the call this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is Tak taking
away your financial piece and you don't
see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with Y refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John this hour
give us a call at
8825 5225 and if you're wondering why
I'm wearing a shirt that just says
deloney on it it's because I'm here to
support my friend John deloney during
his book launch week we're all very
excited about it around here uh and I'm
excited we have a launch party tomorrow
here at the uh Event Center it's going
off man can't wait I uh we've never done
one of these we haven't not with the
level of complexity slash level of um
work I still have to do in the next 24
hours to get this thing we are throwing
a rager on the clock going wild I'm
excited about it well it's well plugs
it's going to be loud yes all right
let's get to Carol in Indianapolis Carol
how's it
going good thank you how can we help
today uh my husband and I are debt free
net worth about a million we have six
months emergency savings
congratulations thank you thank you
after seeing multiple homes over the
last two years we bought a very spot out
after lot so much so we're being
contacted by like private Builders
asking if we want to sell but we're
currently very happy in what we thought
would be a temporary home but we are
growing out of it my main question is is
now a good time to build since I own the
lot do I need a realtor for custom build
um we have about 75 grand saved up for
what we think we're going to build okay
have you started reaching out to
builders because that's really the only
people you need to work with at this
point oh you think it's a good time to
build well the right time to build is
when you have the money and so that's
the beauty of of having that Financial
Freedom so if you're asking is the right
time to build is as far as the economy
goes rates or what because you guys are
going to take on a mortgage to do this
economy we we would have to I mean our
current home is worth about
4805 that we have that's I don't know if
we should rent it make money out of it
no please don't please don't take money
out of it please please please please
please please don't take money out of it
don't put one house on the Block for
another house that's a way to lose them
both okay but we would still need to
take out a small mortgage maybe 200
Grand okay so if you if you sold the
house yes so you sell the house you get
you know let's say 440 out of it mhm and
then you have your 75 that puts you at a
little over 500 and you're saying hey
it's going to cost 700 All In we take
out a mortgage for 200 of
that it might be more closer to eight
now that I think about it okay it's just
so expensive well what's your household
income our household income it varies
from month to month but I could say on
average about 12,000 fantastic so let's
say hey we really need to keep this
mortgage around 3,000 and if we're going
to do that on a 15year we can start
crunching the numbers to go are we ready
for this build are we ready to take on
an $800,000
project or do we need to wait and save
up another 50 Grand 100 Grand to make
this make
sense right we could easily hold off in
this house for no more than two years
okay but it's not it's not too early to
do the homework and go hey let's con
contact a builder let's start to see
what this would actually cost let's see
how much mortgage we could actually
afford based on our income and that will
give you some actual facts versus just I
think and maybe and I feel I like to
have some real num
the facts okay and do I need a realtor
for a custom build no you own the land
you're going to have to I'd recommend
getting several Builders and having them
give you a bid and have some sort of
idea of what you want the house to look
like and maybe and your husband can go
through plans online or hand them to a
builder and say Here's what we're
interested in or look around and ask
people at your local church or whoever
who have used a custom builder we had a
great experience we had a terrible
experience and then interview them at
your house they work for
right and then ask give you Allin cost
and go through that whole process now
the spot a realtor could come in Carol
is their expertise their relationships
with builders in the area their
negotiation skills uh project oversight
resale considerations things like that I
would still say hey there's a lot of
value in having a realtor involved but
do you need a realtor in order to build
a home if you on the lot not
necessarily how do you say goodbye to
them since they helped us by B lot and
our current home ah so are they wanting
in on this because you already have a
current realtor that you
love yes she helped us by our current
home and the lot and she's mentioned
when you're ready to build contact me
contact me and I don't I haven't have
the guts to say goodbye well so maybe do
this call her and ask her what does a
realator help me do what's the value how
are you making money from this what does
this relationship look like and then if
it's if it doesn't make sense for you
guys just say hey thank you so much
you've been amazing but we're going to
continue forward without a realtor on
this one and maybe you do work with her
and maybe it's a huge blessing but I'm
just if you're the question is do I
absolutely need one
no okay I'm saving up to have some work
done at my place and it has never
occurred to me to call a realator maybe
that's on Me Maybe Maybe I'm Wrong on
that one but that's never occurred to me
um I have uh reached out to several
folks who would be either General
Contractors or Builders to come out and
help
me and if I did keep her I would pay her
out of my pocket correct it would you
probably pay a percentage of the total
build yeah yeah that's what I'm curious
about what how the deal would be
structured if she's willing to negotiate
on that but you're not buying a house
she's not finding you a house she's not
searching through MLS and she's not
putting you into a system um it's not a
traditional realtor relationship she
yeah so maybe you're G to pay her 0.5%
or 1% to help find you the right Builder
and I don't think she's going to be
serving as a general contractor making
sure everything that what the Builder's
going to do and so um I don't exactly
know what that relationship would be but
it's if you have a good relationship
with her she's been trustworthy sounds
she like she's been awesome sit down and
say like what would you bring to this
equation because otherwise I was going
to call start calling Builders and begin
to thumb through them that way love it
best of luck Carol that's a big project
excited for you guys all right Christian
joins us in Los Angeles Christian
welcome to the
show hey thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
hey so um I'm a I'm 27 I live at home
debt free um at my parents house uh so I
have no bills uh they don't pay they
don't charge me any rent um I'm
currently making gross 80,000 a year
awesome in savings I have 880,000 cash
liquid and I'm look I don't invest in
anything except for just my uh my
pension plan um so I'm not going to be
able to touch that anytime soon but um
I'm looking to invest essentially and I
looked at the market CDs and or if I
were to throw it at the stock market
into like a mutual fund um I do plan on
using my money to purchase a home within
the next two years um once I have enough
for for a down payment um which is
looking to be about it's going to be
about
150,000 for what I'm looking at okay in
my range so I'm looking at my money is
not doing anything for me right now
essentially it's like I said it's
880,000 sitting in the bank um I'm when
I say liquid I purchased a truck cash um
just because I never had a new vehicle
and honestly I'm considering just
selling it I I'll get 50 50,000 for
right now so yeah you said 130 liquid
that's including if you sold a truck
exactly I have 880,000 cash though and
so I'm looking to just invest since I'm
not I'm can't buy a home right now I
mean the house the prices are just crazy
um they're not going to go down man I
hate to I know everyone says they're not
um yeah I I understand that I'm looking
to I guess my long term goal is like my
Five-Year Plan essentially is I'm going
to just you know stay at home not pretty
much pay no bill just my minimal regular
bills but can years can I push back on
that
why um I know it makes economic sense I
get that but man you got to go out and
live your life you got to learn how to
pay bills you gotta learn how to live on
your own have your friends yeah no I I
get that um I'm just I don't want to
yeah I can go out and get like a cheaper
uh condo I don't want to get wrapped up
in HOAs I guess I'm right now the home
prices that I'm looking at it's like go
go rent you're you're a 27 28 year old
man making Grand a year living with his
mom yeah you're saying I should just go
on rent yes because listen you this is
this is a the math problem you're you're
right the math problem I am able to save
this much money at my mom and dad's
house yes there is the psychosocial
development side of this where you learn
how to be an adult how to be a grown man
and lean on yourself that disc comfort
of having a place making the calls
having to set up your own electricity
call it when the Bill's wrong all of
those things are about being an adult
going to your neighbors and saying hey
we all turn the music down those are all
skills your body needs to learn that you
don't get when Mommy's doing your
laundry for you at 30 years of age so
Christian sell the truck too much of
your world get something reasonable
don't invest this money put it in a high
yield savings account because that time
Horizon is way too short my
friend
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality George Campell joined
by my colleague Dr John delone strictly
colleagues sometimes friends best
friends and we are here for you America
the number to call
aa825
5225 we love having a conversation with
you helping you take the right next step
with your money your life your
relationships all of it Taylor's up next
in Milwaukee Taylor welcome to the show
hey how's it going guys great how are
you you're a little muffled speak
directly in your phone for me a little
muffled is that better
perfect okay um so my fiance and I have
been struggling to pay off a little bit
of our credit card debt and I was
thinking the other night she works she
makes about
14450 a month take-home and she's paying
we're paying $1,200 a month in daycare
um and so I thought to myself why we do
do instacart um in and door Dash and
stuff on the side um and I thought to
myself why don't you just quit your job
put your twoe notice in she's starting
Cosmetology School in the spring anyway
so she's going to have to be leaving her
job when don't you quit your job um and
just do instacart door Dash uh stuff
like that uh fulltime um with our son
staying at home more with him uh and
it's kind of funny I was listening to
you guys a show a couple days ago and I
kind of feel like a little desperate
right now um and I picked up something
that stuck with me and it said that when
you're feeling that's where you're going
to make a you're going to be stupid
you're gonna make a stupid Choice yes
good call man so I thought man you know
maybe I could get on here and talk to
you guys and see how you guys feel about
this what do you feel desperate about
brother just so we're Cur
so listening to the show we've been
paying off we've been throwing all of
our extra pennies um at our credit cards
to we have just over 20 about 20 $23,000
in debt um and we want to take care of
it cuz we want to buy a house so we've
been throwing all of our extra pennies
at it well I had to pay for books um for
my school I'm uh apprentice electrician
ibw and books came do so I went to pay
for my books and I thought I was adding
my credit card payment but I paid the
whole thing so that was a couple weeks
ago and so the last couple weeks we've
been kind
of literally living paycheck paycheck
working out of a negative bank account
trying to catch up because we totally
did not expect that because then a
couple days later her our payment for
daycare um glitched and it double paid
that week so we paid out like $1,500
extra that we were not expecting that
week and so we're finally just that was
a couple weeks ago finally just tomorrow
you know when she gets paid uh we won't
be working out of a negative account we
can get back on track you know working
at her debt um she just got into car
accident Friday so which it might help
it wasn't her it wasn't her fault
someone pulled out in front of her um so
and around about way we might not have
to pay for car loan anymore you know and
we'll just buy a beater car and because
God I don't want to pay I don't want uh
another car so the 23,000 total between
the car loan and the credit cards no I'm
not including that car loan into this if
we include that it's up over 40 but I
don't think we're going to have to I
think yeah I think inome eliminated my
income right now is400 a month um take
home um we I work a lot of overtime with
my job uh and it's temporarily permanent
overtime I guess because with being
those hold on with are opposite words
with overtime you're bringing up 2400 a
month no no no with overtime it's like
3,300 a
month and it's that's consistent for I
know but that's 500 extra dollars right
I'm sorry 33900 extra dollars but I
wanted to use I I don't want to count on
that overtime because at any point it
could get eliminated right here okay
you've got you've got money chaos but
let me just cut right to it dude
underneath that you've got other chaos
what is
it well so a couple years ago we wanted
to buy we really wanted to buy a house
so we thought we could move into my
parents house and save some money uh
well that didn't work Co hit and this
hit and we got Frugal with the money and
it just it just underneath that what's
underneath
that um here's what you sound like to me
okay you sound like a dad you got one
kid or two kids two two
kids is this woman your
wife um no we're engaged we've we've
been engaged for about eight years
why
we I don't know we just have so when we
hold we don't time to go through the
whole thing here's what it sounds like
yeah yeah yeah yeah you sound like a guy
who is fraying at the edges in a way
that makes me makes me nervous for you
the money is symptomatic of a life of a
guy playing whack-a-mole with his
life yeah can I I'm gonna ask you a hard
question you don't have to answer it are
you using right now
um I I drink know yes here's how I know
that the way you are living your body
was not designed to handle the
whack-a-mole stress you put on it and
you have to have something to shut that
system
down either you got to have something to
speed up that system to keep up with it
or you gotta have something to shut it
down yeah I'm I'm a I'm a very anxious
person
yes what you need my man is to uh you
have to have a plan but you got to have
something beneath all this dude let me
ask you what are you running
from failure I guess yes why what are
you scared of man you have a woman who
loves you you got two healthy
kids yeah I mean honestly this might
sound kind of crazy but I've always been
commitment I'm afraid of commitment I've
always been really good at everything I
do but I can't ever just stick with one
thing
okay but when you get lasered in on
something I bet you're freaking amazing
aren't you I'm enjoying my career right
now yeah that's right I am but are you
the kind of guy that's G to get
certified and get a great job and six
months later you're going to be like oh
look over
here um no okay I can't I can't so
here's the deal 33 I don't want to start
over again I love I love what I do I
really do that's amazing that's amazing
you are I need you I want you to do
something crazy when we get off this
call and it's going to sound insane okay
I want you to make a fist and I want you
to put it right in the middle of your
chest and I want you to walk into your
bathroom and shut the door and say these
words out loud I love this
guy and I want you to stare yourself in
the
eyes and my I'd be willing to bet money
that that's going to be hard for you to
do
because right now you have a woman
telling you I love you so much I'll I
will play your little commitment
gymnastics even though we're together
for eight years because she loves you
that much and you got two kids you love
you got parents who are like dude move
on in you have a boss that's like do we
want you so bad around here we're going
to give you extra time cuz we need you
and your skill set and your character
around here the only person I hear in
your life that doesn't believe in you is
you and that has to stop today you got
two little boys you got two little kids
looking up to you
man okay I just called an electrician
and spent an ungodly amount of money you
know what I looked at that guy and I
said I said I trust you to take care of
my family cuz you have a skill set I
don't have please help and he came in he
said I got you that's what you do for
guys like me yeah every day I do that
but you have to address the drinking and
you have to address the
anxiety and you have to address this
pretend I'm not getting married cuz I
don't like commitment but I'm with the
same person I've built a family in a
home but sort of with this woman marry
her and be done with that so your body
can
rest right and then we'll give you a
plan on the money we'll give you a plan
on the money man just got to follow the
plan okay does that I mean does that
sound good it does yeah Taylor I don't
think the solution here is man if she
just stays home our problems are over
you're just trading one problem for
another Wacko and it's not going to get
you out of the money mess it's not going
to be a big dent in the financial hole
you guys have created but you got to get
serious about this if she can get her
income up that will help the problem
we're going to hook you up listen I'm
going to send you building the non-
anxious life my new book I want you to
follow it the second thing is I'm going
to send you every dollar the best money
app for y'all two to use together for a
year for free I'm going to send you the
FPU lessons for free but y'all got to do
them as a couple and make some
commitments and I want you to send me a
wedding invitation in the next 30 days G
game on my brother I'll go with you John
it'll be fun Taylor thanks so much for
the call hang on the line Austin will
pick up we'll get you all those goodies
man wishing you guys the best that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
[Music]
books hey it's John deloney co-host of
the ramsy show did you know over 18
million people listen to the Ramy show
every week a lot of those people listen
on one of our 600 plus radio stations
across the country to find a station
near you go to Ramy solutions.com
[Music]
[Applause]
slow live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it's the Ramsey show
where we help people build weal
do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George camel
co-host of smart money happy hour and of
course leading the charge on the George
Cy YouTube channel joined by Dr John
deloney host of the Dr John delone show
you cat all those shows on the Ramsey
Network and uh and a lot of other places
as well we're pretty much everywhere
these days all over everywhere so give
us a call at aa825 5225 if you want to
jump into the conversation if you've got
that question about money life
relationship ship whatever it may be
we'll give you our best and sometimes
it's not great but it's what you got
free but it is free it won't cost you
nothing all right Nick starts us off in
Salt Lake City Nick welcome to the
show hey um so yeah I I've had a pretty
big life change recently as far as
income goes uh about a year ago I was
making $2,000 a month working at a steel
plant and then my brother-in-law told me
that he thought I could sell and it
turns out I could and my income has now
since quintupled I don't know it would
take me five years to do what I I mean
it's it's an insane jump and my wife and
I are trying to manage it and I feel
like we're hemorrhaging and we haven't
saved enough considering how much we've
made congratulations congrats so what
are we talking are we talking 10K a
month closer to 20 whoa congrats is that
your take-home pay my boss thinks uh for
tax I'm not sure what my that's the
other thing I got to figure out taxes in
this too and so I just oh they're not
taking taxes out nope nope I'm
technically a self-employed
1099 okay so you better be putting away
30% of that every single month in a
savings account I haven't putting away
so we save so we have between our taxes
and then our church donation we put a
side about 45% okay and then we live off
of about well our budget us at 10% but I
feel like we're not doing that is what
we're living off of and then we try to
save the other 45 but that's not what's
been happening how how long has this
been going
on about six months okay cut yourself a
whole bunch of
slack okay yeah like you this is this
rare air congratulations yall had a fun
run and now you got to go be adults and
it's all good okay yeah don't live in
the a Shucks a cuz what you are
experiencing is the upside of sales what
you haven't experienced is when our
congressmen decide to throw tennis balls
at each other just for fun and shoot
each other with Nerf guns and shut
everything down the other side of sales
right you're like a farmer now and you
farm make no money no money no money
then crops and then no money right so
that's awesome you just got a plan for
the future so six months you'all had a
wild time good times and now we got to
be grown-ups right yeah okay so give us
a picture of your financial situation do
you guys have any debt do you have money
and savings so we have a little the only
debt we've brought on was on the advice
of our accountant to try and bring our
tax Li our tax liability down um we
bought my wife a new car um before that
she had a little car that we had paid
off and I have a truck that I have paid
off your accountant told to go get a car
loan he told us to get a loan so we
could not necessarily a loan but to buy
a car so we could use it as a ride off
oh my
gosh dude is Michael Scott your
accountant like how did you think this
was a good
idea that was it's what I've had a lot
of people around me that they said
that's what they did and so that's what
we kind of thought we should do you need
different grounding necessarily but yeah
okay what's the car
loan um it is 32,000 okay the good news
is you have an amazing income and you
can pay this thing off really fast and
it's now not too big of a portion of
your world 60 days got it you making two
grand a month I would be like sell this
car today 60
days yeah 60
it okay days you have you have to make
very focused goals with your money right
now you're in baby step two you have
1,000 bucks in the bank I assume you
have a lot more than that in the bank
right now 15 in the bank 15 in the bank
so this car loan can already get cut in
half today and then with the next few
paychecks bank I guess if you include I
I won't talk about the tax account but
yeah 15 and saving yeah tax account
doesn't that's that is Untouchable we
don't touch it don't touch it don't
touch it it does not exist yes until tax
time and they go hey you owe $60,000 in
taxes and instead of going oh my gosh
you went okay yeah we save for that
great yeah so we're going to pay off
this car as soon as possible then we're
going to stack up three to six months of
expenses in an emergency fund that we
also don't touch unless there's a true
emergency yeah and that's what that's
what this money is for because we live
off of about including the car about
2500 a month because our rent is only
$800 great so this will help accelerate
you to baby steps 4 five6 now are you in
a home you said you're renting you want
to buy a home one day we want to buy a
home next year right now the situation
we're in we got um we got fortunate I
suppose um our my wife's grandparents
have a house that they it's a 42 that
they rent us and so we're in a pretty
good 00 in your Salt Lake
City no well we're close to Salt Lake
Nick you all are winning life right now
you fallen through the a glitch in The
Matrix man this is your chance to to get
ahead that's I yeah I mean it's just I I
mean I just learned I have a talent in
sales I mean I've broken every record
this company had and it just was it's a
lot to handle but also but six months
you can have a lot of talent or you
could have just gotten real
lucky yeah there's that too I don't know
that's the thing right both so it's
probably a little bit of both and so
um George tell me if I'm I'm crazy here
I almost sense a need for you guys you
and your
wife to roll back for May maybe just say
we're going to do a 90day Sprint but
roll back some of the gazelle
intensity remember what it felt like to
be broke and get that laser
focused yeah because if you don't you're
going to wake up in a
mess yeah you're going to buy a house
that you can't afford you're buy a house
based on 20,000 bucks a month and then
the Builder's going to be like what are
you doing you're going to your income's
going to keep going up and you're going
to buy a house based off $30,000 a month
and someone's going to tell you you got
to get a car to right off two and you're
gonna get a BMW and next thing you know
you're gonna be Dave Rams you be
broke yeah so here's the deal you got to
keep living like you make $2,000 a month
for the next six months until you're out
of this hole you're in a great place you
have a financial Foundation you're
investing 15% you're saving money
towards that down payment cuz you have
like a fake life right now paying 800
bucks a month in rent making $20,000 a
month utilize this while you can instead
of the YOLO Vibes that you've been
putting out and you will be in such a
great place financially six months from
now me and George tried to convince
people for three years the government is
not charging you any interest on your
student loans this is there's never been
a better time in human history to pay
them off than right this second your
payments are on sale and 1% I have zero
student debt I know but I'm saying 1% of
America took our advice oh yeah the
other 99 are right now going oh God what
are we going to do similar to you if you
for 6 months pretend that yell are broke
and you get an ENT an emergency fund you
pay off this a car get a new accountant
go to Ramy solutions.com tax get a new
accountant for God's sakes um fire
Michael Scott but you do this for six
months you owe nobody anything you have
six months emergency fund built up and
youall starting a house fund brother
your whole world is different and so is
your marriage everything's different
congratulations man never do it for the
write off that's just life advice for
you America this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camell joined by Dr John deloney
and if you haven't heard our first ever
money and marriage getaway is happening
October 19th through the 21st right here
in Nashville Tennessee just up the hill
from our headquarters at our brand new
Ramsey Event Center and I'm so stoked
about this event and I found out John
I'm going to be a part of it did you
know that I fought hard I made the
lineup to not have you on the lineup but
they're bringing you aboard well John
delone and Rachel Cruz have uh
notoriously headlined this event for
years now but this time it is a full
weekend getaway people are traveling
from all over the country to hang out
and I you're going to be talking about
sex and intimacy which I'm excited to
don't misunderstand John excited to hear
your your sessions or budgeting which is
very
similar yeah both have been known to
cause great joy I'm pretty clear on the
minute by minute I saw recently that I'm
taking baby steps one two and three Jade
will be covering some bud Nightmare and
you will be talking about I love the
fact that I said sex and intimacy and
you were blushing well I was trying to
think a joke I could tell on air that
was familyfriendly we don't have yeah so
it was tough but I will can I tell you
the name of my talk I'll be giving yes
spice it up pillow talk the dirty
secrets of
budgeting I was very proud of that one
and it involves pillows so that's one
reason one many reasons those aren't
pillows excellent George we're going to
have so much fun this really is such a
blast and you and your spouse will be
equipped with tools to cast a vision for
your family set goals create a life you
both love and at the money marriage
getaway you will have the get this
undistracted time to disconnect from
everyday life and reconnect with your
spouse there's going to be interactive
sessions Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney
Jade warshaw myself we're going to be
your guides to discuss money
communication boundaries intimacy and
tickets cost $7.99 for this multi-day
event for couples so if you're out of
debt and you've got room in the budget
please please join us we're going to
have so much fun October 19th through
the 21st come make it a party in
Nashville Tennessee ramsy solutions.com
events we've still got some tickets left
that's the place to go Ram solutions.com
events it's going to be different than
Ramsey events in the past for a couple
different things one is it's not just
going to be us um doing keynote after
keynote after keynote very different
format there's a whole lot of time of
access like here's what we do in our
house let's have Q&A let's talk a lot of
behind the scenes a lot of Q&A a lot of
activity time
yeah so a lot of working this through
the goal is is that um when we leave
when all of us leave we have some tools
to go home and make our marriages better
and we have some time to practice this
with experts and other people while
we're there and there's going to be
other people practicing too so you're
not going to be by yourself and it's not
going to be me and Rachel and you and
Jade do what it's not going to be me and
you and Rachel and Jade what' you
say producer Jame I thought producer
James was talking trash James is doing
the sex talk that was my bad J James
will be talking about sex and intimacy
okay but it's not it you're going to
come away having spent considerable
amount of time with us we're not talking
at you we're talking with you we're all
working on our marriages too so it's
going to be something that we're all
going to do together I'm pretty excited
about it stoked on this event and at
that point I will be the dad of a
two-month-old so maybe I'll do a talk on
parenting I'll be an expert by you are
an expert you are next show you how to
change a diaper like you've never seen
before this is going to be fun I bet
your diapering skills are A+ I try and
I'm a little OCD John A little I try to
get the Ruffles out I try to make the
the little flaps even it's all right
we'll get there let's get to the calls
before James takes us off the air
Georgia is in Chicago Georgia welcome to
the Ramsey
show thank you hello what's going
on um I bought a car the end of July and
I was lied to about the price of the car
um it was some from someone that I go to
church with and um I saw the
contract without looking at it because I
trusted this man and now I can't afford
this
car okay tell me more what do you mean
you were lied to about the cost so they
said it was a certain price and you paid
that price yes they told me on the phone
it was 25,000 okay um um I had gone to
take a trip two days after I bought it
to North Carolina there was some issues
with the car and out of frustration I
was looking at the paperwork I got from
the the sales and noticed
that they had charged me $7,000 more for
the car than what I was
told okay how I'm so confused as to how
you walked out of there having paid
$32,000 that wasn't a red flag to you
like it came out how did you pay for the
car um I went to my credit union but
like I said it was from someone from my
church and I trusted him so after we had
discussed you know the cost in there and
all the taxes and everything and the
3,000 I was going to get out of my old
car I kind of figured it would take me
down to about 22,000 for the car so
after discussing all this with him and
signed a contract without reading it
because again I trusted this
man so it was out of the frustration
when I pulled the paper out of my glove
box um I noticed that it was 32,000 not
25,000 for the actual price of the car
or did they tack on fees
warranties what made actual price what
did he say when you called
him he told me that they had had two
other Ford Escapes on the
lot and probably just got it mixed
up so what are they going to do to make
it right they ain't going to do
nothing I've contacted multiple I I bet
you I have called 30 lawyers and because
I signed that contract this has nothing
to do with lawyers this has to do with
have you gone up to meet imp person with
management not angry and not enraged but
say hey this salesman is a friend of
mine he told me this number he admitted
that they Mak admitted that they mixed
up the cars I want the car that I
discussed with the salesman because you
all switched the cars on
me yes I did and they still refused to
do anything about it even if the
salesman would have told the the manager
that he told me that they still refuse
to do anything about it okay and you've
talked to attorneys and they say
sorry yes okay so if you have a legal
professional telling you their ethical
duty is to not take your money because
you don't have a case that means you
don't have a
case and sometimes they'll tell you we
don't know that you have a case but we
think we can win this let's figure
something out and what they've all told
you is is honey we're not going to take
your money it would be unethical for us
to take your money what does that
mean you found yourself in a quandry and
so I want you to do me a favor okay as
hard as this is going to be I want you
for a while to forget about that man
that you said you trusted because that
doesn't factor into the situation that
you found yourself in now okay did he do
you wrong yes did he lie yes did he not
protect you whatever but you said the
words I kind of figured
and then I signed a contract and that's
that as you as an adult have to say I
also signed a contract without looking
at the final numbers I did take his word
but I didn't do my due diligence also
and here I sit with this thing and now I
got to figure out what to do is that
cool cuz what here's what you're doing
that anger and that rage that you have
however Justified and right it is he's
off doing his thing it's only poisoning
you right yes so let's do our best to
set that down however righteous and
unjust it is you got to deal with a car
that you can't afford So when you say
you can't afford it what does that
mean
um it's actually the price of the car
was 32,000 but by the time you I
attached uh warranty on that I'm up to
38,000 now what is the loan
amount um if I wait seven years $48,000
no not if you s years what was the loan
amount you took
out uh 38
okay and what is your
income uh it's 31 uh 3,100 a month okay
and what is the car worth
today um I'm going to guess around
25,000 okay here's the deal you bought
too much car anyways even if it was
25,000 and so here's what you can do you
could probably get rid of that warranty
and they can refund you for that you can
leave Yelp reviews you can call the
local news and get them to a story but
at the end of the day you got to realize
I got to pay a stupid tax I played a
giant role in this conundrum and you
might have to sell it and eat the cost
of that and come up with the difference
to get rid of this loan and get a
reasonable car but you sure learned your
lesson you're always going to read the
fine print of every single thing you
sign for the rest of your life and I'm
sorry that you had to learn it a hard
way we're hoping for the best for you
hoping this can get resolved from this
dealership Georgia thanks for the call
this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
n
welcome back to the Ramsey Show hey if
you enjoy this show please consider
doing something that costs you very
little time or money and that is
consider subscribing to the show leaving
a review where you're listening and
sharing it with a friend it's one of the
best ways to share the show we have a
marketing budget of of close to zero
because you guys are the marketing
budget because you're naturally talking
about this sharing this hey you got to
to check out this clip you got to listen
to this episode I listen to the Ramsey
Show on podcast wherever you're
listening tell people about it it helps
a ton and we so so appreciate we want to
spread this message to as many people as
possible in the next year all right
let's get back to the phones Sean joins
us in Durham up next Sean welcome to the
Ramsey show Howdy thanks for having me
sure what's going on um so my my wife
and I are an impass on some financial
decisions and since we got ourselves
into clear using Solutions you know 20
years ago we figured we we'd call y'all
to try and try and help us with this
dispute all right I'm team Sean George's
team wife let's go we'll defend both of
your
honors so um we've got a daughter that's
finishing up high school um looking at
college career field that she's looking
at is probably a graduate school type
thing um and just looking at the schools
and looking at the cost of housing um
I'm looking at it and I'm thinking you
know what I'd rather just buy buyer a
place and you know build on an
investment and my wife's looking at that
decision and suggestion and going we
don't take out any more debt until our
home our own home is completely paid off
and you know looking at the baby steps
looking at all the advice Through The
Years we're just trying to figure out if
we're in the same place or if that's
something we should be considering man
John is regretting choosing your team at
this point I am too dang it we were so
close man your wife's right Sean your
wife's right right so you're seeing this
on paper right you're looking at on
paper going man we're going to spend a
th000 bucks a month for the next four
years 6 years might as well get some Roi
out of this is that the idea and Ro Roi
but also possibly a place you could live
in long term um you where going to
investment in my kids um you we're
looking at uh North Carolina Wilmington
I'm on the coast okay so a few hours
from you guys how far is
that it's about two two and a half maybe
maybe three hours on a bad day which
most most days are bad days when people
want to go to the beach okay so let's
say HVAC goes out at this place are you
driving three hours to go fix
it no we're hiring someone to take care
of that okay so that's going to be
something to think about as a prop SE on
that answer what kind of question was
that well it's a possibility people
don't want to pay the property
management fees and what is the cost of
rent out there let's say she lived on
campus or does she plan on living on
campus
um I mean I'm we're we're weighing the
cost right now my my fear is what if she
gets some foam on like man I'd love to
live on campus next year and you're like
no I bought you a place you have to live
there and now you're renting to random
college kids well in almost every
College I know of has a freshman live on
requirement is that
right um she won't technically be a
freshman because of the number of
credits she's pulling because she's
doing College while she's in high school
ah okay so so let's let's back out of
this get to pick's back let's back out
of this and look another Direction
because I do dude I've lived that life I
know the r and board is astronomical
particularly the boarding the colleges
make a significant amount of money off
the board plan with their markup
Professor so I know too there you go so
you know how that game works and so um
um so let's do the well what college do
you work at oh you don't I work at North
Carolina Central University
okay we could talk offline about that so
sure what do you owe on your
house um we owe a 100 Grand we've gotten
it down to 100 how long would it take
youall to do a Sprint and get that
sucker paid
off um our best scenario we for about
three or for about five years we've been
chunking like about 20K into it every
summer off of my wife's seasonal income
so we we've been hitting it hard for a
while our best scenario is 3 to five
years
okay um
yeah just and and that's not figuring
into the scenario of you know we plan on
Bank rolling her education yeah that was
the other question is is this college
completely paid for for
sure we're we we going to basically
shift into pounding down the house into
paying for college okay so I'm going to
say something that's never a fun
conversation but it's unfortunately one
I've had to have probably 10,000 times
in the last 20 years that's I I way
overstated that but such a is
um you're a professor your child has
said here's what I want to do I'm
probably going to end up in grad school
that makes sense that's the path her dad
took it may even be the path her mom
took um both me and my wife went to grad
school for a long time both of us have
been professors all that and you and I
also both
know that every year millions of people
enter in as freshmen with very clear
plans and millions of students every
year change plans meet somebody I met a
girl at a church camp just a few weeks
before school started and I turned down
a full ride to go somewhere else right
so it's all over the place what I would
hate for you to do if you told me hey
I've got cash I want to buy uh a condo
and whatever I would say buy it right
now
awesome but if you saying I'm still
trying to pay off my house we're going
to shift paying off the house into
helping cash flow college and so we're
going to have to take out second
mortgage on a
place man that you're leveraging your
family at and I hate to say it like this
but you know I'm right at the whims of
an 18-year-old and that's a I would tell
you I wouldn't tell you to do that just
for you and your wife if youall wanted
to to have a Airbnb or whatever but even
more so man that makes me nervous that
from knowing how many college students
I've worked with over the years that
have great plans and then Mom gets sick
boyfriend moves my Professor quits they
shut down the program any number of
things happen and suddenly you've got
you got a house payment to make and you
have a a child who's like well Dad I'm
just going to come back home and I'm
going to go to Central and all a sudden
you're like well what are we gonna do
now you see what I'm
saying right I just wouldn't do it yep
yep and I know how hard that board plan
is to to God Almighty how hard that
board plan is to pay for geez man that
hurts it it just it's just yeah I look
at all the hard work we've done and
looking at what would be half of what
would possibly go into our house is just
going out the window well I mean it's
providing here a place to eat and it's a
place to
sleep I mean it's not going out the
window but I see that you're not you
don't have what you project might be a
return on this down the
road yeah seeing they're for a lot of it
like if if you're going to Duke right
she'd be required to live on campus
correct thing so yeah there's no op
there's just so many variables here and
there's if one thing goes wrong this
whole plan falls apart and at 7%
interest on top of your current mortgage
it's going to add more stress than it's
going to be a blessing and I'd rather
see her go get a part-time job while
she's in school she needs to help pay
for some of this I like that game and
you know I I I think kids are resilient
an understatement with my daughter yeah
I think full time's good you're a great
dad I I don't think this is kind of love
you man I wish sea was my
dad Sean buy me an investment condo
please I like my dad but I do like your
like your heart man and I like just try
to think through all this that's
fantastic absolutely well John that
reminded me on this desk a team member
of ours got this a letter for his
daughter from discover the Discover It
student cash back card she's 18
debt-free this man lives by the Ramsey
principles and she's getting marketed
all this very bright pink garbage and uh
it's amazing John how they Market can I
tell you when I saw the envelope I
thought you were going to embarrass me
with like a money marriage Love Letter
I'm not kidding I wish
nope here's here's the Love Letter John
save money while you build your credit
history enjoy 0% intro APR on purchases
for 6 months and then it says after that
your standard variable purchase APR
applies currently 18 to 27% you know how
many 18yar olds know what that
is less than 0 they're not looking at
that all they see is 5% cash back on
Amazon quarterly no interest and here's
what they Market a good credit history
could help you buy a car rent an
apartment and more start building yours
by applying below
goodness gracious Predators man this is
disgusting Predators but hey the cards
are pretty John hey that should be
the that should be a segment on the
George camel show to catch a predator
and you should read um toine print from
credit card companies credit card oh my
gosh uh ads that aree praying on certain
groups of people military folks elderly
folks 18-year- olds everybody yeah hey
parents do yourselves a favor intercept
this junk mail and shred it light it on
fire and then explain to your kids why
they should never sign up for a credit
card at 18 years old this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day 2 Corinthians 4:18
so we fix our eyes not on what is seen
but what is unseen since what is seen is
temporary but what is unseen is eternal
Al Reese said you don't have to focus on
everything to be successful but you do
have to focus on something good stuff
there Addie joins us up next in
Anchorage Addie welcome to the
show hey thank you what's going
on all right so me and my husband are in
baby steps four five and six this is a
question that if whenever I was paying
off my $100,000 in student loan debt I
would have rolled my eyes out because
because we're in a position now where we
can financially afford um to get our
vehicles fixed however um it feels like
this week has just been one thing after
another we have $60,000 in our savings
and a mortgage of 280 we have two paid
for cars and one is what I would say
like a beater we got it and we shared it
for a year it has ,000 worth of um
things that need be fixed on it but my
husband believes that he can handle that
um and so that is our Trailblazer it's
04 and then we have a 2017 Hyundai that
we paid for in cash in 2021 it was kind
of in the um I'm sorry in 20 yeah 2021
it was kind of in the incline of like
the appreciation of um cars used cars
value but we we paid 16,000 yes we paid
16,000 for this 2017 uh Santa Fe
and it was Kelly Blue booking for around
21,000 so we felt like we had a good
deal we had a mechanic check it out and
it has been a good car for us for the
past two years since then we've added
two kids and this week I have been in
the car auto shop place for over six
hours with two children under two and so
I'm frustrated and we have um today I
was told that in order to get the um
Hyundai fix the one that we have the
most invested into it's going to be
$5,700 now I understand that this is
just one person's quote however I don't
imagine that that number will fluctuate
too much going to a different auto shop
in our area and so me and my husband are
presented with the issue to be able to
decide are we going to put in $5,700 in
order to get it fixed and it's not like
a cosmetic issue it's more like an
engine issue or I hope it's not cosmetic
for that much that's wild yeah yeah no I
don't care you should see our TR Blazer
and it's like we didn't even know Alaska
had radio until we got a new call and so
we we piled through we piled through our
debt and moved up here to do that and so
we paid off $100,000 um in a couple
years so we're in a good position um
financially and we have the Savings in
order to just go out and buy you said
you had 50k in
savings we have 60k in savings and that
and 20 of that would be our three to six
months um emergency fund um or expenses
um and so we um
we just put like literally last week put
up the pay off the house uh picture in
order to shade off room by room and then
we get hit with us so we just trying to
decide would you um put in the money to
fix the 16 the Hyundai which is Kelly
weing around $16,000 right now is that
with the repairs that need to be
made um it would not that would include
like if it was just fine and ready to go
so you paid 100 you could sell it for
16 yes okay and if you don't you're
selling it for 10 or
less yes got it and you're wondering do
we do this or do we just upgrade the car
and sell it as is for the 10
grand right so let's say you sell it for
10 and you buy another car with 20
that's 30 you can put towards
something but it would just hurt
emotionally because either way this
sucks you it's not like there's an
amazing shortcut how do we move yeah how
do we move past this we actually have
money in order to upgrade or to fix but
we are feeling like I guess the pressure
of just like okay hold on we don't want
to sink another listen there's no
pressure any pressure you feel is
imaginary anytime I get desperate or I
get frustrated I make stupid choices
stupid yes yes you just spent six hours
in a mechanic shop with two little kids
you should make no decisions none not
even what's for dead for 72
hours every nerve you have it's like
getting like you just have like four
root canals just unfilled right now
right so I would rather fly to Alabama
on a plane with those two than Auto all
day long yes shots fired at the state of
Alabama so listen there there's zero
pressure that's where we're from oh
there we go listen you have $50,000 in
the
bank you have no pressure
here what you have to decide is how you
want to solve this problem but you have
the tools to solve it so any pressure
you feel I would say slow
down 100% chance get another opinion on
this that's a really high I totaled my
car totaled it and they said the repair
um was going to be about 6,000 bucks I
don't know what they're repairing on a
Hyundai for for what is that 5 six for
6,000 bucks who knows maybe they got to
replace the entire engine but it's feel
I feel like you could get an entire
engine for
$66,000 right here's the other piece I
want you to think through I can't think
of a climate that would beat up a car
more than Anchorage
Alaska and I don't know you keep calling
these cars I've invested this money in
you are not you are putting money in a
depreciating asset there is no
investment happening here so you keep
spending money on your vehicles which is
great you have the money you'll work
hard and you're kick and butt I would
not personally um
spend a whole bunch of money on brand
new cars in a climate where half the
year the roads are salted like crazy
where I'm getting rocks and snow and
they're frozen I I wouldn't I wouldn't
invest that kind of money in a really
nice
car for sure and so I think that yall
need a nice dinner and some time away
from this for just a second because
what's going to happen is you're going
to go we have to get a brand new $50,000
car because remember that time we were
in the shop for 6 hours it was awful so
you need
a little bit you make a terrible
financial decision and maybe even this
you know what like I know on the Ramy
show like just make it and then move on
I can see if if let's say this you're my
wife and we're having this conversation
and we both agree let's just bite the
bullet and pay the money and fix this
car if I'm your husband I would go get
the car detailed super nice get the
shark carpet shampoo clean it up maybe
get to put a radio in it I'm going to do
something so it feels a little bit not
like that old car that just cost you an
entire day of your life and $6,000 more
dollars right there's a little that's
that's a nothing it's a token but it is
like a it's an olive branch towards hey
we got bigger goals and our bigger goal
is we paid off 100 Grand and now let's
buy ourselves a home and let's just
don't have one pissed off awful kid
screaming diapers everywhere day in a
mechanic shop and then spend
$30,000 on a depreciating asset that
Alaska's going to
destroy
right I know that's so I don't think we
were helpful at
all take a breather and either way
you're going to be okay y listen you
have
$50,000 hear me say this any anxiety you
feel is
imaginary if you called me and said I'm
a single mom of two kids in Anchorage
Alaska and they told me I have to have
$6,000 and I have no
money then I would be scared to death
for you that's not your situation in the
position where I need to change my mind
in said of we are out of debt we are
free we not like in this stress anymore
and we have the position to make a
decision rather than just what life
happen to us yes now what you're doing
is you're transitioning from you're
transitioning from this is an emergency
to this is super annoying just an
inconvenience super annoying man cuz we
want to do something else for that six
grand like anything else other than fix
this car but here we are I'll tell you
one story John life hack we were going
to buy my car my wife upgrade her old
car it was going to be like 18 grand for
like a Mazda SUV this was back in 2020
and instead we found one that was way
older but it was 8 Grand and I was like
how about this I'll put carplay in it so
I spent like 700 bucks and got the thing
upgraded with carplay and it felt like a
brand new car I drove got deta really
nice it was awesome it was fantastic so
there's always but there's always that
thing in your mind where like w we need
that new car John it's so much more
reliable so much more no you got to get
over it's mostly for ego at that point
just bite the bullet pay the money and
then do one little nice thing to make it
super we both destroy our cars So and
I've seen your car John you personally
destroyed it I pushed your car down the
highway so there that that's a true
story we don't talk about that we don't
talk about Bruno or my Tesla that puts
this hour of the ramsy show in the books
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give
[Music]
generously hey it's George camel if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsey Baby Steps go to ramseys
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started